في منطقة نائية في المنطقة الكردية بشمال العراق ، تواصل
وحدة مقاتلة مؤلفة من النساء بالكامل
تنتمي إلى
حزب المعارضة الكردية
الإيرانية المسلحة تدريب
هؤلاء النساء ، وقد تم سحبها من
خط المواجهة
خلال الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية في المنطقة التي
قامت بدوريات فيها في شمال شرق البلاد.  تعرضت العراق
لقذائف
أرسلتها إيران عبر الحدود ، هذه الوحدة هي جزء من
قوة قتالية أكبر لكل
واحدة من هؤلاء النساء.
قبل أسبوع ، تقع مدينة الشمس
والدودج التي تصفها بأنها موطنها في
المنطقة الغربية ذات الأغلبية الكردية في إيران ، وفي
الأسابيع الأخيرة تم تشبيهها
بمنطقة حرب وفقًا لسكانها حيث
اندلعت الاحتجاجات هنا وفي جميع أنحاء
إيران بعد وفاة ماسا أميني.
ريزان كردي إيراني يبلغ من العمر عامًا فقط
انضم مراهق إلى هذه الاحتجاجات
كنا نعالج الضحايا لكننا كنا
أيضًا مثل معظم الأشخاص المشاركين
في الثورة في الانتفاضة.
من عانت من
اضطهاد النظام الإيراني
نزلت إلى الشوارع والسوق
وتحدت الحكومة التي كنت أشارك فيها أيضًا
ولم يكن لدي خوف من الموت
تقول ريزان إنها بينما كانت تجرها
من شعرها المكشوف مرت
بأجساد ميتة وحتى  بعد
مغادرتها تقول إنها استمرت في تلقي
معلومات عن أشخاص تعرفهم
وماتوا
مثل هذا الرجل ،
وهو متزوج حديثًا يبلغ من العمر 27 عامًا قُتل على يد
قوات النظام الإيراني لدق
بوقه تضامناً مع المتظاهرين
ما يحدث مع
عائلتك أخبرتهم عائلتي بذلك.  بغض النظر عن
عدد أفراد عائلتي الذين
يعتقلونهم ، وطالما أنهم يضطهدون
شعبي ، لن أستسلم
للحكومة الإيرانية الغازية ،
فنحن مستعدون للموت
عندما توفيت الكردية الإيرانية ماسا أميني في
حجز الشرطة ، وأصبح اسمها
رمزًا للقمع.  من النساء في جميع أنحاء إيران
ولكن ماسا ليس اسمها الحقيقي
اسمها الكردي هو جين ، وهو اسم
منعت السلطات الإيرانية عائلتها مثل كثيرين
آخرين  مجموعات الأقليات العرقية من
استخدام النظام تسجل بشكل قانوني فقط
الأسماء الفارسية ، ولكن في آخر لحظاتها المسجلة ،
لجأت جينا إلى استجداء
خاطفيها بلغتها الأم الكردية في
معاهدات تم تجاهلها مما
عزز مخاوف الأقلية الكردية في
إيران من وصول إيران لقمع الاحتجاج
داخل حدودها  تمتد الصواريخ الإيرانية إلى
أبعد من ذلك بكثير
خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ،
حيث سقطت الصواريخ الإيرانية في المنطقة الكردية في
العراق كل يوم تقريبًا.
قناة تلفزيونية محلية تعرض اللحظة مباشرة بعد أن ضربت
طائرة إيرانية بدون طيار وعدة صواريخ
إحدى قواعد أحزاب المعارضة الكردية الإيرانية
مما أسفر عن مقتل ثمانية جنود وإصابة أكثر
في يوم قالت السلطات الكردية إنه سقط فيه 70 صاروخًا
في غضون أربع ساعات فقط من
هذه القاعدة  قبل عامين فقط كان على
خط المواجهة في القتال ضد إيزيس
بعد بارك ريك  بعد التدريب الأمريكي ،
لم يكن بعيدًا عن قوات سينكوم التابعة للقيادة المركزية الأمريكية
بعد يوم واحد فقط من
الهجوم على قاعدة العبوات ،
أسقطت طائرة إيرانية بدون طيار أخرى يبدو
أنها تمثل تهديدًا لقوات senkom
المتمركزة في المنطقة وباعتبارها الولايات المتحدة
المناهضة لـ-  من المقرر أن يستمر وجود تنظيم الدولة في العراق ،
لذا فإن التهديد الذي تشكله إيران
قد تعهدت هذه الرذائل النسائية بالقتال
حتى يتم تغيير النظام في إيران
، يقولون إنهم يشاركون جينا ألمها الذي
يطلق عليه اسم فرضه
عليها نظام قمعي.
اسم كردي مثلها لم يتم التحدث به
خارج منازلهم جميعهم يقولون إنه من
الصعب تخيل العودة إلى ما
كانت عليه الحياة من قبل